hey guys how's it going welcome to my
Thanksgiving dinner video I am really
excited about this video I'm going to
show you guys how to make a really
simple easy Thanksgiving dinner for you
your friends they might not be your
friends after they have your dinner but
always worth a shot alright first steps
first we're gonna make some mashed
potatoes we're gonna make some turkey
and we're gonna make some cranberry
sauce so get all of your ingredients and
lay them out like so I told my family
that I make mashed potatoes they're like
you do know that you have to cook the
potatoes I thought I was just gonna
throw them into the blender mix it all
up but I was told that I need to boil
them first so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna boil the taters yeah get
your potatoes of course juggle them
first just to just to make sure
everything's really nice and even
okay potatoes are actually quite awesome
to juggle ready in do the pot oh God
potato down we'll just disregard that
one I've got a little visitor here no Bo
no piggy see hello to the internet guys
this is Bo what do you think about
Thanksgiving dinner
you don't care all right go back to your
bed I'm leaving a hominid like I should
put in here but I'm just gonna put
everything that I bought a lot of water
I think I'm gonna get rid of some
displacement probably show you got a
bigger pot use this while our potatoes
are cooking I'm gonna start the
cranberry sauce
so for cranberries we're gonna need
cranberries put those in the blender
looks good that looks a lot more than I
thought now while we're starting our
cranberry sauce I want everything to
sort of just all start cooking at the
same time so instead of roasting a
turkey which I found out takes a really
long time we're not gonna do that here
I've got this nice package of turkey
breast
that's real hungry see I have this right
here this pan when I bought the pan and
had a turkey on the inside of it so I
thought this would be what I would need
so split you hear that all kinds of
things going on here all these things at
once let's move you a little bit closer
so we can get a nice nice shot of what's
happening I don't think anything is
happening to our potatoes yet but let's
get our we should probably pretty heat
the oven oh gosh oh my so for our turkey
all we got to do is open up this package
into the pan like so get out come out
turkey I might have got a pan that was a
little too big I spent a lot of time in
the grocery store trying to find turkey
gravy and I couldn't find it I got
frustrated everybody was trying to get
their Thanksgiving shopping done so I
didn't get the turkey gravy
I needed that for my stuffing but I
think we're just not going to use it
we're gonna make our stuffing a special
way our turkey is nicely prepped in our
pan for baking roasting whatever you do
with or again Oh God are you all are you
even heating up next we have our stove
top turkey stuffing mix these directions
really got me huh you need 3 cups of
chopped Turkey you need a package of
frozen broccoli and cauliflower and you
need a jar of turkey gravy I couldn't
find the turkey gravy so I'm not sure
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna see that my
mom has a new pantry as mom's have
everything she's probably gonna actually
need it for Thanksgiving dinner so so
worthless okay we're gonna just use a
little bit of this this
some free-range chicken broth a chicken
and turkey they're basically the same
exact thing so I don't care if you're
here to learn how to really make things
giving dinner you've cut bigger problems
it smells nice we're gonna just dump
this on to our on top of our turkey now
my thought process is when I put this
into the oven it's all gonna get really
I don't know what my thought process is
I also I just got this to go on top this
is the honey roasted turkey it comes in
a nice little baguette so I'll just open
that right up and we're gonna place this
on top of the stuffing that we have on
top of the turkey breast and then we're
going to take a little bit of this
chicken broth and since I didn't have
turkey gravy which I recommend giving
turkey gravy if you could find it at the
grocery store but I could not I could
not find it we're just gonna dump some
of that in here we're gonna need a
little more stuffing mix I think for
sure that's gonna burn it's okay we're
gonna add a little more chicken broth
thank you yeah so stop into the oven we
go so stop
now it's time for our cranberry sauce
this should be really really really
simple I'm thinking that I should
probably put a little bit of sugar or
something in here because that's what
the recipe said to do there's no need to
measure at all because we don't do that
here it said about a cup so I ain't
about that measuring life it also said
that I should put cinnamon in there so
that's what I'm gonna do also couldn't
find out of the grocery store well
that's a lot thank you in them are we
ready for liftoff oh my gosh
here she goes good work good work do
your job
yeah so Starbucks like its make it okay
I'm sure smells kind of good look I'm a
cranberry sauce you made myself yeah I
freakin made it myself
okay guys now is the time that we have
really all been waiting for I think the
potatoes are about boiled I mean they're
starting to boil cranberry sauce
complete little set aside what is it
what do you think I don't even know what
I'm achieving I'm not even sure what I'm
trying to achieve here so the question
is if it will blend then it's soft
enough finals you a little test with
these two taters is it bad to blend
something if it's like boiling
okay I'm gonna need a stick I don't
think he wants to see why can I not
blend full potatoes let's just try one
this is what we need look at this
success
let's turn it up let's turn it up
all right two potatoes in oh hey why
don't you put your out of boiling water
getting it all I did I did it's freaking
hot
you're so stupid you're so dumb Justine
it's like your mind has not developed
yet - potato okay you guys want to see
what it looks like and you go
I made mashed potatoes all right mashed
potatoes need to go into their origin
their own rights mashed potatoes going
in Oh looks like we got a whole potato
here listen save that for later
Cheers stop second second right now it's
the moment we've all been waiting for
the plating of the Thanksgiving dinner
we've got our mashed potatoes our
cranberry sauce
our turkey let's up put the turkey onto
the plate all right yeah gonna place you
right here look at that look at this
steamin too late easy to make dessert so
I hope my guests enjoy a nice pie crust
some chocolate chips and some pumpkin
filling first we're gonna have some
mashed potatoes so it's just up there's
a full potato right there little bit of
cranberry sauce just let that me really
it's gonna take a nice little slab of
our turkey I want to leave enough for
all of my guests right through that
middle see what it looks like look at
this it looks beautiful it's nice and
moist too
um
so it's like perfectly fun if I gave
this to somebody they'd be like this is
really good but the mashed potatoes are
absolutely disgusting it's so dark I
think I might have put a little too many
cranberries in thank you guys for
watching I hope you enjoyed how to make
a Thanksgiving dinner I will tell you
what this turkey was actually quite good
the rest of it needs a little bit of
work I hope you guys have an awesome
Thanksgiving I am extremely thankful for
all of you guys your friendship your
internet love you're all amazing so
hopefully you're spending some fun time
with your family your friends and if
you're just sitting at home playing
video games
that's just a ok - I love you guys I'll
see you later be sure to like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
for more videos and most importantly let
me know in the comments below what you'd
like to see me cook next I'll see you
guys whenever I see you bye
Oh